Robin Wright author of the book in the
name of God the home aney decade how
much influence you think the Iran
relationship with this country has had
on this country in the last 10 years oh
I think it's had not only an immediate
impact of the trauma of the hostage
ordeal the impact of the confrontation
between the u.s. and Iran and the
Persian Gulf the shooting down of the
Iranian aircraft I think it's had a much
broader impact and that is it along with
Vietnam prove that the United States was
an was not invincible
was indeed very vulnerable and the third
world powers could not only stand up to
us and defy us but occasionally could
even defeat us and so I think it's had
an impact on our national psyche and on
our policymaking apparatus did they
laugh at us behind the scenes over there
no I think they've always been a little
bit frightened of us they've always
given us credit for having more power
and more planning more conspiracies than
we deserve I think they were proud and
pleased that they were able to stand up
to us but I don't think they were
laughing at us why did you write this
book I wrote it because of my own
experience in the Middle East I lived in
Beirut for years as a correspondent for
the Sunday Times of London and during
that period I witnessed the marine
bombing in 1983 when 241 American
military personnel were killed the two
embassy bombings
two of my very best friends are hostages
including Terry Anderson who at the
office next door and it was my own sense
of rage and misunderstanding of the
situation I wanted to find out why this
was happening to the United States why
there was this tremendous antagonism
between two countries that had been such
good friends and so I kept going back to
Iran I first been there during the Shahs
era in 1973 and I kept going back and
back and back and finally I came to
grips with why it was happening what it
meant and answered some of my own
questions I don't I don't have any
sympathy for the Revolution but I
certainly understand now when's the last
date in this book that you were able to
write about how many staff he died the
weekend I was writing the last chapter I
may be the only American grateful to
Jimena for anything
because it was going to be subtitled the
home a new era and so I got in the
complete time of his rule in Iran why
the name in the in the name of God
because that's the basis the
justification for everything Iran has
done over this decade carried out in the
name of God be it acts of violence
against the United States the war with
Iraq the taking of hostages both
domestic and foreign policy were shaped
around God's laws and carried out in
God's name do you ever meet home Annie
no I didn't I met several members of his
family and talked to them at great
length and they had some unusual insight
but in the last years of his life
Khomeini was was never interviewed it
was the first period that when he got
back when Oriana Fallaci and various
other people who were there at the time
got to see him when his family did you
meet met his son Ahmed it was a very
powerful man in his own right now I met
his daughter who has some very
interesting kind of family type stories
about what it was like growing up in the
home any household how she would fight
with her brother and how many how home a
knee would settle arguments like a
normal father which is not the way we
picture him in the West that's for sure
another daughter some grandchildren they
like well they're human beings just like
the rest of us I don't don't agree with
a lot of the things they said but it was
fascinating I said to get some exposure
to someone it's like being within the
inner circle of of the Pope or moammar
qaddafi I mean good or bad the closer
you get the more you understand them and
that's I think one of the great things
about being a journalist we can go off
in places like Iran or Libya where
American foreign policy makers can't
American diplomats can't and so we have
access and we can begin to understand
and hopefully transmit that at least to
some of our readers you're living Tiran
no I went there quite often stayed there
for long periods of time but never live
there if somebody told you yet living
Iran for the rest of your life
action me there are places I'd rather
live many places what's good about it
well here on is a what is good about
Iran I guess one of the what concerns me
most is the stereotypes that are wrong
and for example that how meny tried to
take the revolution back to the seventh
century at the time the faith was
founded by the Prophet Muhammad in fact
there are there are many attempts to
modernize they've kept on many of the
modernization products started project
started by the Shah building a subway
system in Tehran building new project
new development projects I think that
their their focus their hatred was
channeled against the West so it was a
westernization that was synonymous with
modernization that so turned them off
and there's still many sides of life
where Iran Iranians are approachable
they're open in life for women is better
in Iran than it is in many of the Gulf
shakedowns with which we have good
relations their women in Parliament
there are women in the ministries 51% of
Tehran University a year ago was counter
for by women's students so there it's
not that what is good or bad about Iran
it's a different culture and it's and I
think unfortunately one of the problems
in the West is that we tend to look at
things if they're like us they're good
and if they're not like us they're bad
and I found things that were comfortable
for me as a westerner and things that
were unusual what was comfortable what
was comfortable well I think the
accessibility after all it's an
interdependent world now and even a
country that's going through a
xenophobic revolution turning away the
outside world still is open to people
who will listen and a lot of Iranians
were willing to talk I was always
surprised be they hardliners or the
so-called pragmatist and with each trip
I got to see more and more high-level
people including the head of the
Revolutionary Guards who admitted that
they had trained the man who drove into
the marine compound where I had lost
friends it was almost
surreal experience I talked to the
interior minister that what the Stalin
of the Revolution is he's called manny
mota Shah me who who talked about his
links and the establishment of the
Hezbollah or party of God cells in
Lebanon while he was ambassador to
Damascus I mean it's it's not as closed
off as one might appear they still know
a great deal about us they get the
Washington Post in the New York Times
and their libraries and their think
tanks their newspapers in both English
and Farsi run a lot of news about the
United States not all negative either I
mean straight wire service stories from
The Associated Press
the tragedy is that we don't know as
much about them there's still 10,000
Iranian students who come to the United
States for education but we every well
it's gone down in fact it was much
higher in the early 80s they had foreign
exchange problems and so forth that
limited the number of foreign students
they could afford to send overseas why
do we allow that oh I think that we hope
that exposure to our culture will help
defuse some of the tension of the past
decade
Kent Americans go over there and study
if they want to know and one of the
tragedies is that even just a year ago
there was not a single foreign service
officer learning Farsi when we have so
isolated cut ourselves off from Iran
that there's no one who really has now
the exposure the experience in trying to
understand it so that if we do get to
the point that we try to better
relations with Iran because the
revolution is not going to go away we
don't really have the skills the
background knowledge which to do it
we have no ambassador oh no we have
interest section run through the Swiss
the interesting thing that is marching
Tunisia have an interest section too
with 90 Iranians in it we would have the
right if we wanted to to have Americans
working in a foreign embassy the Swiss
the Belgians some Ally if we if we so
chose but the fact is no one after the
hostage crisis of November 1979 is
going to risk possible dangers of
another hostage crisis when was the last
time you were there just about a year
ago
why did you go I went twice last year
once because of the shooting down of the
Iranian aircraft and once because of the
end of the war the Iraq war the
iran-iraq war which lasted for eight
grisly years you write that when you do
travel you wear the veil all women
foreigner Iranian have to wear either
the shut door the all valving black veil
that covers everything with the face the
hands and the feet or a job headscarf
and very loose clothing just that does
not reveal any curves and you have to go
into the country that way so you dress
that way before you leave wherever your
demarcation point is it depends on which
airline you fly if you fly in Iran air
yes if you fly in a foreign aircraft
carrier you can dress at the last moment
and there other little things I mean you
know you have to be very careful no
makeup I once we had my red nail polish
on and forgotten to take it off and the
stewardess reminded me and of course I
had no nail polish remover and accepted
my luggage and so it gave me ten
band-aids to put on the ends of my
fingers and I went through customs and
pulling out my money to declare the
immigration of course everything went
flying and the immigration official
leaned over and said are you badly
injured and I laughed and pulled off one
of my band-aids and showed him and he
laughed I mean there is a undercurrent
of understanding these days you can wear
pink nail polish my last trip I managed
to wear pink and and I was not
reprimanded things are loosening up now
I think that the passing of the ho meny
era the the threshold marked by his
death means the more flexibility not a
dramatic change but far greater
flexibility in economic matters and
commerce with the west as well as
diplomacy I think we're going to see a
rocky but eventually steady course
toward bettering relations with the
outside world last will be the United
State
and it will be probably a long way down
the road but I think we're headed in
that direction finally when you travel
to here Ryan how do you get there
there not many carrier airlines that
still fly to Tehran so usually I go
through Frankfurt it's the one West
Germany has very strong trading
relations as does Japan with Iran and so
I usually go through but it's amazing
the airlines are always booked and there
are no Super Sabres and it can be one of
the most expensive places to visit in
the world and Tehran in fact is one of
the three most expensive cities in the
world for people who live there for
foreigners you travel both and one of
the things about the economy that's so
troubling troubling the regime and
troubling for the average Iranian is
that the legal rate of exchange for the
dollar is 20 times its legal value so
that a little box of cookies that would
cost eight dollars if you were paying in
dollars will cost a hundred and sixty
dollars if you're paying in reals and
the average Iranian can't afford that
that is it's still a third world country
and despite its oil the per capita
income is is fairly low and a taxi to
run a taxi for a day just an ordinary
old car with a Iranian driver will cost
you 250 to three dollars three hundred
dollars a day two tires can cost a
university professor two months salary
it's a tremendously expensive place to
live when you go there what do you stay
I stay at the old intercontinental or
the old Hilton which had been renamed
one is called the independence which
symbolize what the Iranian Revolution
was all about and the other one is
called the tulip which is the symbol of
martyrdom what language do you speak
French English I know 50 words of 50
languages including 50 words of Farsi
but I've never had a language problem
one of the things that you keep reading
through your book is it that no matter
how hard we try we can't understand
these people they tell us that you tell
us that and you tell a story and I think
the prologue about having a drink or cup
of tea or something with someone in a
small cafe would you tell us that story
as an example of the difficulty and
understanding
this was a civil servant who had been a
longtime contact and we were having
melon juice and coffee cake one
afternoon and and he was telling me how
disillusioned he was with the regime
that if his son became of age the war
was still raging he would get him out of
the country that he hadn't voted in the
last presidential or parliamentary
elections didn't even know who was
running that he was very discontent on
at every level and wished that they were
back in the Shahs date not because of
the Shah but because of the way of life
during that period and then a friend
called him away and told him that radio
Israel and the BBC were reporting that
how meny was dead it was erroneous it
was one of the many false reports before
how many did die it came back
ashen-faced and told me the news and
then he said this is terrible for my
country what did he mean I think he
meant that that were all the bad things
that were happening in Iran there were
many Iranians he and others who though
discontent believed that home Annie had
Iran's best interest in mind that he
made misstep but he was one who was
powerful enough to stand up to the
outside world and his death would mark a
time that the nation would be left
feeling more vulnerable when you visit
Iran and you don't speak fluent Farsi
how do you make contact and talk to
people and they speak English well
there's a lot of English a lot of French
this is a very cosmopolitan country and
up until the revolution I mean everyone
was in and out of Iran and the funny
thing is even the old Kentucky Fried
Chicken franchises on the downtown
corners of Tehran have changed their
signs they now say try our very own
fried chicken and they have a picture of
someone who looks very Muslim rather
than Colonel Sanders but you go inside
and the owner will tell you sure enough
they still use the same old recipe and
it's smells just like Kentucky Fried
Chicken they have been exposed Iranian
particularly those who've lived in the
cities and the vast majority of them do
now have such a sophisticated knowledge
of the outside world have always had to
because of trade and commerce Iran has
been the strategic juncture between East
and
West the crossroads and so they're
speaking three or four languages is not
unusual at all do you get a sense when
you visit the people that they all
follow this leadership right now they
all believe in what's happening in their
country no I don't I think they're
they're believers on two levels one of
those who are in the minority now I
suspect who believe that the revolution
is still very much alive still very
strong and they believe everything
Roth's and Johnny says or everything
particularly at home a nice ed I think
there's another level Iranians have
always been strong nationalists and they
need strong leadership and when they get
that kind of leadership they are
attracted to it they they made moan and
groan and grumble all the time but at
the end of the day they they worry about
the alternatives or someone weak or
succumbing to the West even those who
admire America were educated here had
some pride at the time of the revolution
that a third world country could stand
up to a superpower and get away with it
and one of their goals during this first
decade despite the immense costs of the
Warrens of work included paying off the
foreign debt accumulated by the Shah
that amounted to billions of dollars
despite the fact they didn't really have
the foreign reserves to do it they
needed to buy military equipment they
needed it for development and so forth
but they felt that was a means of
freeing themselves from outside
influence from being beholden to others
and they proudly point out that they
were doing doing this at the same time
the United States was becoming the
world's greatest debtor nation got here
a map that I want the audience to see
how much of this country have you seen a
great deal of it over the years I did a
lot of the kind of standard things one
does during the Shahs era saying Isfahan
Shiraz and seeing some of the more
beautiful places in the country since
the Revolution I been seeing areas like
the war front a lot of time in Tehran
mostly in the West probably at any time
that Iran is an issue you can't turn on
your television set without seeing your
face and hearing you talk about why is
it I think it's in part because there
are so few Americans who've been
interested in Iran have made the effort
to try to understand and willing to to
spend much time the Iranians are also
not very good about allowing the press
in and they usually have what we call
windows of opportunity where for four
days there's a big event home a nice
death an election the shooting down of a
plane and they allow the entire forum
prescient and then they expel its entire
foreign press I did something unusual I
started applying for visas and sometimes
it would take 8 months 10 months but I
said I wanted to go to Iran these were
the kind of people I wanted to talk to
and I think maybe being a woman also
helped a bit because I was less
intimidating or frightening the fact is
that they knew I had lived in Beirut
written about the Shia the religious
sect that dominates in Iran and it is
also the largest sect in Lebanon made
them think maybe I was serious about
this what did you get your interest in
the first place Oh everything in my life
has been an accident I started as a
foreign correspondent years and years
ago 20 years ago and was first in Africa
and loved it and then moved to Europe
and discovered that it was nice place to
live it wasn't much of a story and so
moved to the Middle East and one could
not live in Bay in Beirut in the early
1980s without understanding the Shiites
and understand Monsieur I it's always
led you back to Iran and because I'd
been there in and out of there before I
decided to go back in the introduction
of your book you say to the memory of a
thoughtful law professor who advises
students as well as his children to
approach all problems quote by standing
on top of the world and looking down
unquote and who was so much more than my
father what's that all about my father
always taught me as a child that when
there was some major issue that one had
to distance oneself from from it to try
to stand on top of the world without
having the subjective values that
and impede or limit judgment and he was
always interested in foreign policy and
we traveled a lot as children and he
would try to explain other cultures to
us and so I guess what I tried to do
with Iran was to go there to stand on
top of the world and look down at Iran
not just as an American with my own
bitterness but as someone objective
trying to see what the revolution set
out to accomplish and the book actually
begins from the something called the
roof of Tehran which is the top of the
mountain reached by antiquated cable car
and looking down at this extraordinary
Capitol and looking at life a decade
after the Revolution what it what it's
like in the acknowledgments you go
through a lot of people but the last
sentence says last but never least has
been the inexhaustible love and
encouragement of my mother you dedicate
as your father deceased dedicated and
then you acknowledge your mother where
did you grow up and what influence did
your mother and father have on you
beyond what you just told us and how is
that how did that get you to where you
are now did it influence you to become a
reporter not necessarily become a
reporter but to be curious about things
enormous Lee the first book I wrote I
dedicated to my mother who has visited
me in most of the nine war zones I've
covered and that dedication read to a
woman whose only comment when I covered
my my ninth war was how marvelous to be
able to witness history and he was so
much more than my mother
they were marvelous parents who
encouraged their children to expose
themselves to other cultures to get out
there and ask questions and be curious
about things and those little kids we
used to play geography around the table
you know you begin with Georgia and I
take the last letter which is a and come
up with
Arkansas or someplace and we we expanded
that too as we grew older to include all
parts of the world as we traveled and so
forth and became a great game that we
try to discover the world and where were
these places and what was Burma like and
what about Zambia and of course it was I
grew up in the 60s during the wave of
Independence in the third world and that
was an exciting time not just for
America but what was this you know 84
countries have become independent since
World War two more than half the
countries on earth and kind of
discovering bits and pieces as the world
of all it was a great adventure or was
home I was born in Ann Arbor Michigan
and then I went to a boarding school
briefly in high school in Switzerland
went back to Michigan and college and
then went straight into reporting and
within a year of working but then the
Christian Science Monitor I was
traveling overseas was your dad a law
professor at Michigan and you went there
yes your mom work while you're in school
or both of them were academics mother
gave up a lot because she was one of
those women who kind of got caught early
she danced with Agnes DeMille she was an
actress she still does plays at the age
of 73 she just got back from Eastern
Europe last year she was in China she's
a great adventure too how has she been
able to visit you in nine war zones
doesn't visit me at all in one case an
army beat her in she was scheduled to
come in and they came in and took the
capital there no more flights she flies
in and she's she's a great both my
parents were great political sightseers
when they came to South Africa to visit
me when I was based there they didn't
want to go to the game parks for the
mountains or the Cape shorelines they
wanted to see Soweto and they wanted to
see how Parliament functioned and I
guess I inherited a lot of that kind of
interest in political sightseeing and
all the wars you cover what's the most
dangerous situation found yourself oh
there are a lot of them I suppose Angola
was the most hair-raising in that one
battle there were only 16 people who
made out of 350
made it out alive I went down to cover
some British mercenaries I'd been on the
Cuban side and I want I want to do all
three sides and I went to in with these
British mercenaries and the Cubans
rolled in people had just been with and
we took a small tugboat across the mouth
of the old Congo River River now called
as ia River just where it meets the
Atlantic in a terrible storm and and
boat caps from a car bomb and a hotel
room from artillery fire I mean every
war there's been something the side of
my rib cage is crushed I mean you know
you pick up these little war injuries
even being a correspondent do you ever
get tired of this in extremity were you
taking all these chances no because the
opportunity to witness history is just
so amazing
for a little girl from Ann Arbor
Michigan to be able to have traveled
with the Pope and to have interviewed
Qaddafi and to have seen some of the
great turning points in modern history I
mean what an opportunity one of the
things that in your acknowledgement you
talk about the Carnegie Endowment for
international peace here in Washington
what role would that play in writing of
this book I spent to Marlys years there
which offered some time to sit back and
reflect on Middle East policy on a u.s.
foreign policymaking apparatus on the
world in general I'm one of those who
believes the worlds in the state of
great transition and I think to be able
to to see how that applied to one
specific region and to look at it at
broader levels in terms of the use of
religion and politics in the late 20th
century one of the world's most secular
age ages to look at the impact of war
prolonged warfare on society and on
children and so I had a great two years
there how does that work how does
someone get two years to reflect on the
Carnegie Endowment for international
peace you have to ask Carnegie about
that every case is different
are they pay for it and where do you do
this it was a think-tank and dad by our
Andrew Carnegie in 1910
and they bring in foreign policy
specialists from academia from foreign
policy community some journalists who've
been foreign correspondents and it's
like a faculty without students who
write and think and lecture and talk
among themselves about things that are
happening in the world what did you do
right after that kind of experience then
I joined the Los Angeles Times why'd you
do that well I guess a journalist always
has this divided feeling I'm in my 40s
now and I want to do serious things but
yet you don't want to give up the
opportunity to get out there and see
what's going on in the world you can't
give them up can't give it up completely
so I when I wrote the first book I
taught it at Duke University and ended a
pointer fellowship at Yale and to give
myself some of the meteor credentials
but you still there's something
addictive about about journalism in all
this time had you ever get a sense that
you want to be on the other side of the
line and be in the government no no let
them make the mistakes it's more fun
being the critic sure I mean there are
there are times that one two thinks
about it could you do it could I have
done it better and I'll never know
because that's not my role what role
behind the scenes does a journalist play
with officials of the government do they
often come to you and say tell me what's
going on you find yourself I mean you
ever are you ever concerned that they
want to know more from you than you're
willing to tell them oh sometimes but
there are two different kinds of
relationships one when you're a foreign
correspondent overseas and diplomats of
all nations are primary sources and
there is often a dialogue between the
two what do you hear what are the
indications what what are the future
scenarios scenario izing is one of the
most fun games of being a foreign
correspondent and then back in
Washington it's a as you know better
than I it's non clave and we all end up
talking to each other again because we
cover them and they want to know what
we're hearing there's a there's a
dialogue I think
and differs from individual to
individual looking at a picture of home
Amy and by the way if I ever pronounced
pronouncing these names just correct me
because I'm sure that there's a better
way of pronouncing them well how did he
ever get to where he Bri ended up
but what call us the qualities did he
have it made him a leader I think he was
a man who emerged at just the right time
for Iran at least in its in Iran's
context he was a man who had fought all
of his life for Iran's independence I he
had personal qualities such as
extraordinary charisma he was able to
talk to the he was a great communicator
much like Ronald Reagan was he could
talk to the people in ways that made
them trust him believed him
that was a an ironic similarity between
the two men who clashed so often but he
merged also in context of a country that
was going through a very troubled period
throughout the 20th century this race to
modernize and to westernize and a lot of
Iranians were saying we are a culture
that dates back 2500 years even 5000
years why should we be being dictated to
by this young upstart nation that's only
200 years old I mean we should not
abandon our history our culture our
traditions in order to become an
imitation of something else we have to
be true to ourselves and I think he
emerged because of his own personal
qualities as well as the context of
political dissent in Iran at the time
there were no other alternative
political alternatives there was strong
anti shah feeling but leftist rightist
marxist none of the groups could provide
the kind of leadership that home-a nee
did was he a writer he was a scholar
wrote some very very heavy reading type
books and
that have some interesting
interpretations about Islam it's it's
funny in a way we in the West think he
took the revolution back as I said it
before 13th centuries when in fact his
was in many ways the most modern of
revolutions in terms of the issues that
addressed things like modernization and
westernization as well as the technology
used I mean he is the first
revolutionary leader to lead revolution
by remote control
he wasn't Cuba it wasn't Castro in Cuba
marching through the mountains or Mao
and China on his grand march through the
countryside he did it through
long-distance cassettes and
long-distance telephone calls it's quite
amazing was it at where the cassettes
audio or video predominantly audio I
think there were some video or some
films and things that they got through
towards the end but the the tape
cassette was was really what made the
difference people could listen and and
the bazaars in Iran you know in mixed in
with the tapes of Elton John and
everything else you could find the home
aney tapes tell us his pattern of living
what when was he born where was he born
and when did he first leave the country
he was born at the turn of the century
in the town of ho Maine at that time
Iranians didn't have last names that was
one of the modernization introduced by
the first show the Shahs first pallavi
show the last Shahs father in the 1920s
and 30s he was born in the town of
haumene many mullahs take their names
from the village where they were born
for example roughs on Johnny the current
president he was born in roughs on John
there are some who keep names because
they are long-standing family names or
family communities but many of them when
came time to become a mullah then add
the name of their village to their name
I lived in a simple mud brick home his
family was of limited means but both his
father and his grandfather had training
as clerics grandfather in fact had been
quite noted he grew up at a time when
education like education in other parts
of the third world earlier at the same
time primary means of education were
through religious in
little boys went to the clerical schools
to learn to read and they learn to read
the Koran
just like in Africa the missionary
schools were the first source of Western
education so and he became a mullah
early on in life became a very serious
scholar and by the 20s he had begun
teaching at the same time the former
dynasty in Iran the kadjar dynasty was
crumbling an overthrown by Colonel in
the Iranian army who then crowned
himself King Reza the first and started
the toward modernization
he was avenged throughout that period
there was a constant conflict to
conflict between these two men they they
epitomized the two different visions of
Iran one was to modernize to become you
know to bulldoze the bazaars and the
suit the religious institutions and the
old symbols of the old way of life and
build supermarkets and and all the
things that were terribly modern and
there was the other side Romanians
vision which was we can modernize but we
cannot lose sight of the of Islam and
the process is too important that life
is not just about material things there
has to be a spiritual side and the two
men fought from their different
institutions the first Pallavi King was
forced to side forced to abdicate in
1941 because of his pro-nazi views and
that's when his son inherited his throne
and that's when the rivalry show that we
get to know the Shah that we got to know
that's when the rivalry began to really
heat up and by the 60s it was it was on
the front burner and it becomes so
volatile that the Shah forced home a
knee into exile where'd he go he went
well he wandered for a while he went to
Turkey and was unhappy there then spent
most of his time in exile in Iraq
teaching developing a network of
students and then the final few months
in Paris before he returned to Tehran
the dialogue on the audio tapes came
from Paris oh they also sent across from
Iraq he had
he had Romania it was sixty years old
before he started opposing the Shah
actively I mean taking a frontline
position against Shah Mohammad Reza I
want to show this map because those have
maybe never seen the map in this way can
see where Iraq is over here and the
border goes right along here that's
about a 700 mile border 730 miles and
and how many spent some of his time over
here in southern Iraq yes in Najaf and
he set up a he was he was teaching he
was and he had a group of students some
that came from Lebanon and it
subsequently played a major role in the
anti-american violence in Lebanon others
who came from Iran other Iraqi Shia he
had a group of students who came from
all over the Middle East and they in
effect formed a network that once they
went back to their own countries
provided support from home a knee in
their own societies was it while he was
in Iraq that he how to characterize it
how where he grew to dislike the Iraqis
or the leader I think that there was
some personal animosity
besides the the fact Iraq has always
been a problem for Iran because it the
majority of the population is also
Shiite but it is run by Sunnis and
Sunnis and Shiites the two major sects
of Islam Sunnis are about more than 80
percent the Shiites are more than 10
percent and they've been long-standing
rivals since the the great schism within
Islam of the seventh century there's
been a rivalry of who controls what and
how meny felt that the Iraqis had not
treated their own Shiite population well
so there was there was a political issue
but there was also a personal animosity
between home aney and the current
President Saddam Hussein and it was
Saddam Hussein in 1978 who expelled home
a knee and so the war that subsequently
played out played out a lot on a
political agenda and geographic
strategic issues but there was also a
lot of personal animosity between two
men loathes each other
back to home Annie what are his other
qualities you say he by the way what is
a mullah a mullah is a priest it's um
anyone who goes through seminary writes
enough scholarship to be deemed a kind
of priest it's not a formal procedure
but anyway he becomes a Mulla Mulla is
the lowest ranking a Grand Ayatollah is
the highest ranking and these are not
appointments or elections these are kind
of when the community when the following
that you have deems you worthy of
something then they call you an
Ayatollah you go their different stages
and they they mean things different
things you know a mirror of God a
reflection of God the voice of God and
so forth was he a good speaker
he was magical he could enthrall
Iranians both with his piety and with
his prose and often in in the name of
religion you had a lot of death through
his direction did did he ever explain
that well I think most Iranians will
argue that they are not defying the
Quranic or Islamic and Junction's
against suicides and so forth but they
felt that that they were defending
survival of the faith they looked for
example at the deployment of the u.s.
Navy in the Persian Gulf in 87 and 88
not just as a conflict trying to contain
Iran but as an effort to contain Islam
much as the outside world blocked the
path of the Prophet Muhammad in the 7th
century now to you and me that's a
ludicrous of course that's not what we
were doing in the Persian Gulf but they
genuinely believed it after all why
would we be in the Persian Gulf I mean
that had no more justification than for
the Iranian Navy to be around Cuba it
just didn't make sense to them
geographically so that must must mean we
had an ulterior motive and and you know
they have a different way of looking at
at the relationship at at the role of
Islam in society they look at everything
in terms of religion
the revolutionary leaders do that does
not mean that average Iranian does but
the revolutionary leaders do and that's
hard for us who for those of us who live
in a constitutionally secular nation to
fathom because religion is so private
for us how many people live in Iran 52
million in Iraq it's about a third of
that a quarter of that in the war that
just recently concluded how many
Iranians lost their lives well there the
other conflicting claims the Iranians
claim it's about a hundred and twenty
thousand when in fact the estimates for
the entire war in terms of casualties
deaths and injuries go as high as a
million so it's somewhere in between i
I'm not sure we're going to know with
the Iranians from your experience
talking to them over there were they in
favor of that war I think that there
were many who felt that Iraq invaded and
had no grounds to and so nationalism
can't became a big factor in rallying
support a lot of people who were opposed
the regime felt this was an incursion
that everyone must get out and fight so
yes they supported the early stages of
the war I think toward the end because
of the use of chemical gas by the Iraqis
because of the War of the cities in
which long-range missiles were fired in
communities that had not been exposed to
the war because of the high death toll
that a lot of Iranians became very
disillusioned with that conflict the
book did you actually physically write
the whole time here with Carnegie no I
didn't I
Carnegie doesn't allow books so I wrote
it after I after I left yeah when do you
write he's an early morning writer no
I'm a late night writer I get home I
work during the day so I get home and I
have a computer home and I I finally I
have a wonderful big old house in
Georgetown and I finally moved my
computer into my bedroom because I was
spending no I was either as one or two
places and I figured I might as well be
realistic about it
you did a couple of things in this book
that you don't often see one of them is
this right here we'll get a close-up on
a cast of characters what is it it's a
list of the people who appear in the
book because there
foreign names and it's often very
difficult for us if it's not a Smith or
a Jones to remember them and so I wanted
there to be a list how did you decide
what names to put in I actually tried to
limit the number of Iranian figures I
use it using just the big names the
well-known names so that there wouldn't
be too much confusion I tried to keep I
wrote this book for the average American
to help them understand Iran not to
apologize for Iran but to explain it so
that that somewhere down the road there
was a wonderful Iranian who said to me
you thought you understood Iran because
the Shah spoke English and because his
cabinet had read Shakespeare but you but
you and the Shah failed to understand
Iran because you were looking for
reflections of yourself and my goal was
for us to understand Iran and try to
accept it without looking for images of
ourself when you look through there are
a lot of names that I personally
remember during the whole hostage thing
that were oblah Hassan Bani Sadr
whatever happened to him he's an exile
in France continues to speak out on
Iranian issues very unhappy with the
course of events in Iran or Bani far
kobani far was executed oh go by far I
know he was the one involved in the
iran-contra I was thinking of goats by
day the former foreign minister who was
executed for planning against the
government kobani for is probably
somewhere off in Europe after the
failure of iran-contra probably trying
to keep a low profile make some money
who knows
did death did you ever talk to any of
these people the last couple years able
to reach any of not Bani Sadr is some of
his information is good but it's hard to
tell what part of it is good or not I
choose to go and try to see it for
myself and I find that more more useful
when you consider to be right now the
leader in Iran that you would most want
to follow there believe what they say I
think the new president raphson Johnnie
is clearly the man of the future if he
can survive politically and physically
there have been a number
of assassination attempts against him
shortly after the Revolution and more
recently I think he is the man who will
shape the post ho meny era will
determine whether or at what stage the
United States is approachable and with
you know it can be dealt with again he's
a man who is very shrewd there's a
wonderful anecdote about him in Tehran
that the foreign minister and the former
president and Rafsanjani were in a car
and they came to a t-junction and the
driver said which way can I turn and the
former president said turn right and the
former Prime Minister said turn left the
driver turned to Ross and John and said
what do i do on raphson Johnny said
signal left turn right how did he get
where he is he's an unusual man he was
again came from Ross and John and did
his education all through through edges
schools studied under Hall mania is a
very young man in the city near Tehran
called Combe which is a theological
center and became very active after
Romania was expelled in keeping a live
home a needs vision and for that he was
imprisoned at least four times by the
Shah one of the posters I saw it still
up in Tehran shows a picture of
Rafsanjani in his prison garb without
his white turban in prison overalls with
a number underneath showing that he the
time he had been spent in jail but his
his family was in this pistachio
business his brother went to Berkeley
didn't graduate but spent at least four
years there and now runs Iranian
television and it's very funny because
he keeps up with what's going on the
United States through the down leg of
satellite they get so he sees Nightline
every night and will when I've talked to
him has talked about recent programs on
on Nightline
as I said there they're not isolated
from us does he speak English very yes
very good English and you have talked to
him before yes
yeah it's been a lot of time talking to
him and when you go over there and if
somebody you said that they're often
windows of opportunity if you got a
window of opportunity in the next couple
of months would you go there oh I always
go to Iran I think that they will not be
pleased with my book because at the end
I say home a knees how many did one
thing for the Revolution he survived ten
years and during that period he helped
entrench it but his greatest failing was
well he did fail his Revolution because
in the aftermath of the of the war the
ending of the war a year ago Iran had
begun almost pell-mell to open up to the
outside world renewing relations with
France Britain and Canada holding
international trade fairs to which
companies from all over Europe and the
Western world were sure looked like
there was going to be this basis for
commerce again foreign European hostages
were released in Beirut it really looked
like there was movement and then
suddenly in February as Iran celebrated
its 10th anniversary home aney issued
the death edict on Salman Rushdie for
his book Satanic Verses
and then he fired his heir apparent for
basically saying things that were far
too pragmatic for home Annie's taste and
he was their parent
Ali Montessori who no longer but he
fired him but that was pulling the rug
out from underneath a movement that was
gaining great speed Iran looked like it
was going to take its place among the
community of nations again and he left
all of these people who were had set
that train in motion basically totally
exposed and now I think that there
Rosslyn Johnnie is under a lot of
pressure because that was the last
message how many left and therefore it's
going to be very difficult for him to
deviate too much from that too quickly
without his revolutionary credentials
being questioned who controls his future
well he does more than anyone else but I
think there are opposition terms of
Mujahideen okok the people's Mujahideen
is a
an Islamic group but also a Marxist
group has challenged him Ross and Johnny
has claimed that opposition groups have
been behind assassination attempts
revolutions are not single events they
are processes and this is in effect a
new stage of that ongoing process it is
going to continue to be a revolutionary
and therefore a volatile environment if
you pick up the telephone and try to
reach him when he take your call
no I doubt it if you I don't think he
takes any calls directly if you went
there to visit again what do you see you
now oh I don't know I mean he does like
to see the press he often that's his
medium for sending messages to the
United States or to other people with
whom he's interested in communicating if
an American just wanted to go to Tehran
right now and applied for a visa could
could one get one if they weren't a
member the press there are some
Americans who've gone over recently for
conferences held at Tehran University or
at the foreign ministry think tank it
would depend on your interest your
reason someone government going to
sponsor you there are some Americans who
still live there's a man who runs the
travel agency of all things married and
Iranian likes environment estates from
San Antonio and he speaks with a strong
Texas twang draw whatever it is in Texas
there are a number of American women who
married Iranians and have stayed there I
met one who'd been there 53 years and
she wasn't going to leave even though
she was sweet little white haired lady
from the quest and but she managed to
survive the Revolution I want to go back
to something you said earlier we're
talking about students you say there's
some 10,000 Iranian students that are
here in this country that's the rough
figure how do they get in apply for
visas they get they apply first to
universities and if they're accepted
then they apply for visas and the US I
think has quietly encouraged that not
made it easy they're looking for they're
not looking for trouble in the United
States but I think that this is often a
way we expose other cultures to the
United States after all with this our
geographic separateness from so much of
the world
means that people don't know us as well
know our culture as well either and
that's a good way to build friends maybe
remember some time ago reading I think I
saw a chart in the New York Times it
showed the number of students from
around the world in this country and
Iran LED and it may have been near that
at the time there like I remember 36,000
students were supposed to be here from
Iran why do we have and at that time so
many Iranian students well during the
Shahs era there were even more than that
largely in the liberal arts humanities
but as well as some of the professional
fields but because this was that was the
way to get a good education if you
wanted a really good education you went
abroad whether it was to France or the
United States now there are fewer in
part because of foreign exchange
problems in Tehran and now they're
studying different things medicine
engineering agriculture those things
that will promote development in Iran
this is very provincial and it's
something that I've experienced here but
you can there are a lot of Iranians
around the Washington area and you can
just assume get an Iranian cabdriver
coming out of Dulles Airport is anything
and I've had lots of conversations over
the years when you arrived in this town
and one of them told me one time that
don't believe what you see on television
he was very much committed to being out
of there but said don't believe what you
see on television the government pays
those people to get out there in front
of the embassy or whatever to
demonstrate is there any truth to that
story oh I think there are often times
that the government pulls out martyrs
families or its friends and brings them
to prayer district you know very
important celebrations or prayer
services and so forth to show that
there's still this great fervor I don't
think the renter crowds necessarily but
it's interesting that Iranian who lives
in this in this country says that and I
have to tell you for every time I've
come back from Iran it's almost uncanny
I always get an Iranian at the cabdriver
from Dulles I've had two former Admirals
in the Navy and one former Commandant of
the commander of the abadan fleet who
are now driving taxis out of Dulles and
they've been fascinated and wanted to
know everything about their countries
and many of them still have relative
there would like to go back why do they
do what they do why do they come here
and and drive a cab well I think that
there was a great fear during the early
stages of the revolution particularly
during the the very bloody reign of
terror that ended in late 82 early 83
because of the purges the executions
there was no future and it was better to
get out alive and drive a cat some place
than to endanger execution at home one
gets a sense that there's a network of
there's a citizens band radio and you
can hear them talking to their friends
around it do it are there a lot of
Iranians that live in this area or in
our lot of Iranian 's that live in the
United States the largest Iranian
community outside Iran is in Los Angeles
why'd they pick Los Angeles probably
climate place for you know new
enterprise and development I think some
went there in panic comfortable I mean
they're large Iranian communities in a
lot of cities in Washington they're
Detroit a lot of places but I think
there's something like 400,000 Southern
California back to your book again in
the back of the book you devote a lot of
pages to a thing called chronology
what's that for I wrote a long
chronology of the revolution trying to
group events military political whatever
together so that those of us who have
seen only those limited pictures on
television or read little bits when from
correspondents who got in during the
windows of opportunity could fill in the
gaps could see what happened could fit
together the pieces the goal of the book
was to give an overview of the 10 years
I didn't want to have to deal with every
specific event so I chose to put that in
the chronology how'd you do this
Oh laborious process of going through
something that brought the United States
government puts out called a foreign
broadcast information service going
through every single headline to try to
track things drawing on other journals
it's it was a real labor of love to try
to figure out what was important and and
what Americans would take an interest in
and also notice an acknowledgement you
listed a lot of professors different
schools around the country did you have
people read this manuscript for
I drew on everyone because I drew on
everyone from iranian-born scholars to
people who were involved in iran-contra
to former hostages to some of my
colleagues who have been to Iran I tried
to get everyone involved in offering
additional perspective background one
other thing on your book in the back you
also do a thing called source notes how
comes so much documentation because it's
a controversial area and I want to make
sure that anyone who thinks that I'm
saying something controversial knows
that it is that there are good footnotes
and that there's a source for it that
it's not just a journalist book but it's
a thoughtful serious work as well do you
consider yourself at the Los Angeles
Times only an expert now in Iran or do
you have a worldwide beat I have a
worldwide beat I do national security I
focus because of my experience in the
Middle East a lot on terrorism on things
like chemical warfare I'm also now in
the process of looking at kind of some
of the broader political changes in the
world some of the new themes emerging in
ideology and socio-political forces such
as ethnicity religion and politics the
changing nature of warfare after nine
wars I think I have a right to kind of
look at where the trend is headed
because while the super powers are
disarming the third world certainly
isn't and I think things like chemical
warfare missiles are going to
increasingly be controlled by third
world countries that are not only using
them producing them well Iran plays
bigger role in our country's future in
the next 10 years as it has in the last
10 years hopefully not but it's going to
be a volatile period for Iran and of
course whenever that country goes
through a volatile period it spills over
into the United States I would hope that
in the next year 18 months that there is
some kind of resolution of the hostage
phenomena so that we can give back to
the really serious issues that are
important to to the two countries I'd
also like to see my friends freed
did I read that you said something
affected it takes 360 billion dollars to
rebuild the country
well the estimates on reconstruction
after the war are range from 350 to 500
billion dollars I mean we're talking a
lot of money and one of the problems too
is that many of the the kind of things
that you do every five years whether
it's painting a room or reinforcing a
bridge or whatever haven't been done and
there's an awful lot of basic
infrastructure they're unaffected by the
war that needs to be attended to our
guests for the last hour has been Robin
Wright and she is currently with the Los
Angeles Times this is what her book
looks like in the name of God the home
80 decade thank you very much for
joining us thank you